[Music]
this is a story about ireland and it's a
story about an event that you've
probably heard of
but might not know much about
it's usually called the irish potato
famine
in most history books the irish potato
famine doesn't get a lot of attention
at most it appears as a pretty simple
story to explain irish migration abroad
in the beginning
irish people depended on the potato for
food
then there was a potato disease
many irish died and others migrated
abroad on what they called coffin ships
to england scotland australia and north
america but the story of the famine is a
lot more complicated and a lot more
disturbing than that it was much less
natural and much more artificial than
you might think
and it all goes back to a man named
thomas malthus
malthus was a british economist and in
1798 malthus put forward an influential
idea and a rather counterintuitive one
malthus said that when food production
increased people were better off for a
little but that improvement led to an
increase in population which eventually
caused societal problems
there were too many people and not
enough food to go around
poverty and famine with the natural
results
like animals malthus said
humans had a certain carrying capacity
when it exceeded that carrying capacity
enough people would die to return the
population to a natural equilibrium
so in the 19th century
that so-called malthusian model became
the conventional wisdom
in european intellectuals
it led them to focus on what they called
overpopulation and made them think of
famine as nature reducing population to
a sustainable level
[Music]
no serious economist today will tell you
that having too many people is the
reason people are poor
or hungry
in 1981 the economist amartya sen
explained the real cause of most
historical famines
if you look at the historical record sen
said
a collective lack of food is never the
real problem the cause of famines while
it often has something to do with a
decline in agricultural production
is more related to the unequal
distribution of food
there's enough food for everyone but
some people can exchange what they have
for that food
sen found that famine is usually not the
result of too little food
but of exploitation and unequal economic
relations
irish people were the other against whom
the british could define themselves they
were viewed as lazy barbaric barely
human
ireland itself
was run as a colony for the emerging
class of british capitalists
while england was rapidly becoming the
wealthiest country in the world
ireland was kept incredibly poor
the population was almost entirely
composed of peasants
the large majority of all houses were
huts
made of mud
and the land those peasants lived on was
owned almost entirely by absentee
english landlords who never visited
ireland and extracted exorbitant amounts
in rent even the british government
regarded these landlords with disdain
calling them quote
the most oppressive species of tyrant
that has ever lent assistance to the
destruction of a country
so most irish people were on a treadmill
of extreme poverty
they were the most destitute people in
all of europe
in many districts one government report
found
their only food is the potato
they're only beverage water
a bed or blanket is a rare luxury
and that part about the potato is
especially important
ireland has a lot of fertile soil and a
topography that is ideal for grazing
cattle
but when the british came in and
colonized ireland they systematically
took that land and used it to produce
beef for the domestic english market
and so the economically poor irish
turned to the potato
a versatile crop that could be grown in
large numbers on bad soil
and while the potato was adaptable it
was also really unreliable there had
been widespread potato failures pretty
much every other year in the 19th
century
and in the 1840s
a new potato disease originally from
north america arrived in europe
huge potato crop failures sprung up in
northern france in belgium and in the
netherlands
but none of those places were as
dependent on the potato as a source of
food as was ireland
so when the disease got to ireland in
the 1840s
the results
were devastating
in 1845 about a third of the irish crop
was destroyed
by 1846
75 of it was gone
hunger spread rapidly
with unprecedented severity
this period became known in ireland as
andrajil the bad life
but as amartya sen observed this wasn't
just about a pure lack of food
in fact during the entire period of the
famine ireland was continuing to export
food out of the country enough cows
sheep pigs and grain were being shipped
out of ireland that could feed the irish
population twice over
but the british government refused to do
anything about it
soon the irish began begging their
british overlords for relief and early
on the conservative party government
then the representatives of the old
british aristocracy had a fairly
sympathetic response
they bought food from america and
brought it to ireland distributing it to
the poor
but in 1846 a different party the whigs
came to power in britain and the whigs
did not have the sort of aristocratic
paternalism that the conservatives had
they were advocates of a philosophy
called laissez faire
the idea that the free market left alone
would solve virtually any problem
so the person they put in charge of
famine relief in ireland was a man named
charles trevelyan
trevelyan had been a colonial
administrator in india and he was a big
believer in those mathusian ideas about
population he didn't really want to stop
the starvation
he thought it was well
necessary
the famine trevelyan said was quote an
effective mechanism for reducing surplus
population
he said
it was the judgment of god that sent the
famine to teach the irish a lesson
the real evil he said
is not the physical evil of the famine
but the moral evil of the selfish
perverse and turbulent character
of the irish people
so trevelyan's solution to the famine
was to let it ride
the laissez-faire wigs decided to change
nothing
they refused to stop the movement of
food to england and limited the amount
of food they offered to the starving
irish people
the food that was being imported into
ireland was largely used not to feed the
irish
but to feed the cattle being slaughtered
for british consumption
even when they did offer some relief to
the irish peasants
they instituted moralistic tests
requiring that recipients live as
indentured servants in a workhouse to
improve their work ethic the british
even required that food only go to
people who owned almost no land
forcing impoverished farmers to sell all
the remaining land they had to their
landlords many of whom
lived in britain
and so
the famine only got worse
diseases of hunger like typhus dysentery
and cholera spread wildly killing just
as many people as the lack of food
social structures broke down
ordinary people turned in mass to
begging crime prostitution in western
ireland some resorted to cannibalism the
british fearing a rebellion
sent army troops instead of food
as the news of the famine spread all
over the world
shiploads of food finally began arriving
americans from all strata generously
sent money and food over the atlantic
only to have their donations met with
huge british cargo fees upon arrival
even the choctaw people donated to the
famine relief funds just a few years
after they had experienced starvation
themselves on the trail of tears it was
a beautiful example of international
solidarity but these donations weren't
enough to stop the ruthless exploitation
by british landlords even when enough
food was being imported
it wasn't getting to the irish people
starvation and death continued
impoverished irish with barely enough to
eat
were evicted from their homes
one priest remembers the scene of a mass
eviction
several hundred human beings were driven
from their homes in one day and sent
adrift on the world
to gratify the caprice of one who before
god and man
probably deserved less consideration
than the last and the least of them
the hard scenes i had then witnessed i
must remember all my life long
the wailing of women the screams the
terror the consternation of children
the speechless agony of honest
industrious men
rung tears of grief from all who saw
them
by the time the famine began to end in
the early 1850s about 20 percent of the
irish population
2 million human beings had died of
disease or hunger
another 2 million had left for brighter
shores
today ireland's population is still
lower than it was in the 1840s
but ireland has never forgotten the
famine and the generosity that some
showed to them
during covet when the people of the
navajo nation were hit hard
ireland repaid their kindness shown to
them during the famine by raising 2
million dollars
and ireland has never forgotten those
who did not help them
the british government and all those who
valued profits
over humanity
as the british historian ajp taylor
would later write
the english governing class had the
blood of two million irish people on
their hands
all
ireland
was a belsen
i'm rory duffy
professor of history and filmmaker for
the gravel institute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you